we formed five gotrons and those gold
transformed the go-go tron
[Laughter]
awesome
i love it welcome back to new rock stars
rick and morty season five episode seven
gotron jerry cisric van gaalion
the voltron episode we've been waiting
for seeks to redeem episode four's giant
incest baby while
exploring rick's weird but totally
understandable obsession
with gundam stacking or voltron stacking
whatever you want to call it but really
what numerical base secret
could be driving rick here oh wait math
just enjoy the episode what
this is rick spain our rick and morty
after show where we obsess over robot
exponents to give you your hot takes i'm
eric voss
my easter egg breakdown of all the
details you missed is coming out
tomorrow but here
i'm with little ricky wrap it up to my
hot head rick
tommy victol
yes oh my god combining uh
voltron or whatever any of those shows
with goodfellas i felt like this episode
was this was for me so i feel like
someone made it for me
best of both worlds i mean this is one
of my favorite episodes
of like all time top five at least
favorite of this season
i was i was able to see this episode
earlier i've been dying to talk
about it because i was it's so much fun
uh well tommy break down what happened
in this episode it would be
my absolute pleasure okay well rick
diverts a
trip to boob world tragically to
complete his collection
of ferret go trons which he ropes the
family into piloting
just so he can stack them in the style
of voltron or power rangers
and fight giant insect monsters rick
gets greedy
it assembles families from alternate
timelines to uh in his growing
gotron operation which gets which is all
getting co-narrated
by morty and summer in the style of
gangster films like goodfellas or the
godfather
and uh oh my god there's so much good
stuff about like
not knowing when to stop and like
getting too big and
he even says too big to fail at one
point right yeah we're too big to fail
which is like
you know great famous last words so
obviously everything goes awry rick ends
up
firing the original family and replacing
them with their rival anime gotron
pilots who of course plan to sabotage an
oust rick so summer and the others save
him using her giant incest baby from
episode four
named naruto
i love that and in one of my favorite
post-credits scenes of all time
the insect monsters are revealed to be
well-meaning misunderstood beings just
trying to communicate the cure for aids
i know what the hell what i feel like
when you
yeah i know just for that i mean a pinch
of sea salt
right like two parts lemon juice like
don't cut them off keep going we're so
close the stuff we all have in our
kitchens
there's no way once you cross through
this void you'll just become a giant
screaming
alien with no clue naked to them they're
naked or maybe you will
we don't know there's no way of knowing
oh but that's classic that's so great uh
now we're gonna dig deeper into rick's
obsession with his gotron stacking
but first of course if you want to help
us make more great content new rockstars
one of the best ways you can support us
is go check out our merch at
newrockstarsmerch.com
we got some black widow inspired designs
in the shop including our latest
obsession the red deep
design and some fun russian nesting doll
designs support this channel and get
yourself some cool swag by going to
newrockstarsmerch.com
tommy what's our our big question all
right so
what's the real secret behind rick's
gotron stacking obsession yeah for those
of us who grew up with
voltron and power rangers we all
innately get rick's obsession with just
combining one cool robot with another
cool robot into one bigger awesomer
robot and then stacking that robot with
other stacks
to create a huge awesome assembly of
robots it's just
it's just a crazy uh infinite obsession
that we all have that
also you could argue explains the um
combining the avengers with the
guardians of the galaxy and they all
combined now now they fight thanos and
it's just
it's just toys it's just toys it's all
just toys and it's
you know it's like it's a lot like the i
mean even in dragon ball
and dragon ball z and dragon ball gt
where it's like well
we had him go sane now he's got to go
super saiyan now he's got a fuse and
then they go super saiyan
now they can explode planets like it's
like it's just
just heightening and heightening and
heightening and heightening and
heightening height and heightened
to sell more toys right right digimon
pokemon they do the same thing
right like you gotta collect them all
you have to have them they're little
toys and then you can also buy physical
versions of this when you go to kp toys
but for rick this isn't just a childish
fantasy it is largely a childish fantasy
but you can also think of this as rick's
idealized vision for a way to connect
with his family like in earlier seasons
this show was clearly about the power of
two
rick times morty and that was because
morty emitted inverse brainwaves that
canceled out rick's brainwave so that he
could stay hidden from other bricks
but now rick has been more fixated on
what i call the power of five
finding ways to keep all five smith
family members together doing something
that he considers worthwhile
without any need of a b plot that
separates them remember he snapped at
jerry
about this in the decoys episode he's
like no no
no we're we're not going to split off
into a b plot that's stupid let's just
stay together and then
they did stay together and that led to
this wonderful decoys
insanity that is similar to this episode
structurally and with gotron rick
finally has his perfect answer to this
because all five
family members are linked together
they're working in tandem they're doing
something awesome
each feeling valued and he loves this so
much
he gets greedy he grows it exponentially
he brings up the
five families taken from godfather he uh
squares it to form the go-go-tron which
is 25 total robots and then drunkenly
cubes it to form the gogogotron
which would be a total of 125 total
robots
and then the writers cleverly include
this little moment when rick is drunk
alone in his office and reveals his
ultimate vision
which is never fully realized thank god
in this episode
he says and then the gotrons make the
gotrons make the gotrons make the
gotrons yeah he's clearly working his
way up to
five to the power of five which would be
3125 total robots and
in rick's drunken delusion
five-dimensional perfection
but the reason it falls apart is that
rick's family members are not him
obviously they ultimately don't think
like he does and thank god because when
he replaces them with people who do love
gotron's as much as he does
they turn on him try to kill him and not
and then only rick's family members care
enough about him to not let him
die because the power of numerical
harmony and crystalline
order are no match for the power of
family
even when that salvation comes from
bloodline incest
god oh my god i mean what do you what
did you think about
that this episode i i i think you're
right i also think that there is
a simple i mean like that explanation is
i think the correct like
kind of intellectual argument i also
think the simple answer is this is
modeled after a sitcom where
the main character has a thing they want
to do it gets out of control
and the way you reset back to normal is
the supporting characters eventually
come
and save the day saved by the bell every
time zack morris had a crazy scheme
eventually lisa and screech who were
like the more
you play it safe people came in and
saved the day so i mean to me
the the math stuff is all fascinating
and and correct
widely correct but i think there's also
just this i think the writers had a
little fun with just like
i think classic kind of sitcom structure
with this a little bit of like you know
well we've gone way off the rails and
the only way this goes back to being the
show that everybody knows and loves
and not just everyone dead by the hands
of anime characters is uh
at the end the most powerful message of
all your family will never leave you
especially if
they're a 20-story tall baby that is the
product of a brother and sister
artificially inseminating
uh to save the world what a dark
disgusting
solution but it works it works logically
you know you were comparing this to
classic sitcom i think this is like
classic american uh film yeah right like
yeah
the classic american story is
entrepreneurial character
discovers some kind of magic tonic uh
that uh you know changes everything
and then gets some a bit of success gets
greedy
tries to uh uh horizontally
expand his operation uh flies too close
to the sun
gets burned collapses to earth and who's
there to catch him
the most unappreciated person in his
life but the people who stuck by him
yes and that's the story of citizen kane
uh that's a story of good fellas most of
these gangster films that's a story of
movies like american hustle
that's the story of uh what's the uh
mcconaughey
leto movie oh uh dale spice club dal
spires club
these movies take so many different
forms and different genres and it's
because that is like the american
mythology i mean it's
literally the story of that envy movie
with jack black
yeah it's the same kind of story there
you see it tragedies rom-coms
everywhere and it reminds me a lot of
that um
of the chicken fingers episode of
community
it's the same thing there that was a
good ella's episode yeah and that was
the episode of community where i was
like oh
this show's even better than i thought
that was a pivot point and i love that
this episode kind of brought back the
same kind of influences you see the same
kind of thing instead of chicken fingers
it's go trons
yeah it just works really like just
really briefly
uh at the beginning i was wondering if
they recorded
new audio or vo
to address the uh backlash
of the incest baby episode i was yeah
did they because i'm like you know in
animation
i you know i think i've said before like
i used to work at family guy in a
non-creative capacity don't go crazy
uh in a legal department almost but uh
but they would
you know record pretty close to the i
mean they had jokes about seth
macfarlane
uh hosting the oscars how he did hosting
the oscars the week
two weeks afterwards so it was like they
put that joke in
they went in an emergency re-recording
so at first i was like
i mean these are essentially the mouth
movements are not they don't really
match the words that are you know
you just your brain tricks yourself into
thinking the characters mouths are
moving in the correct way i was like did
they re-record all of this just to
address this controversy
and i think the even more diabolical
thing is that the
staff knew that episode was going to
push people the wrong way
right no yeah i mean i think you're
right i think
i mean they animated the giant incest
baby this is part of the storyboard for
sure so they must have planned it this
way
uh at the very least i i my conspiracy
brain is thinking was this episode
intentionally leaked early because of
the backlash like they wanted to show
fans they're like no
you're going to bring back giant in
suspect we didn't just do it as a gross
throwaway gag it's going to have some
kind of creepy
role to play in the future but like i
think they the writers must have been
aware that when they introduced giant
incest baby that
it was gonna have a reaction yeah i
don't
but i think you're right i think it is
possible i mean animated shows do
do adr lines that they throw in last
minute i mean south park especially is a
show where they
they do it in six days you know and they
throw in stuff this minute
for sure um the animation though takes a
bit longer but uh
we do actually want to talk more about
this old giant incest baby's return
and uh whether it was worth it but uh
first
wouldn't think some people helped us
make this episode this summer bespoke
post is here to take your adventures
to the next level with a new lineup of
must-have box of awesome collections
bespoke post partners with small
businesses and emerging brands
to bring you the most unique goods every
month in the past
i've gotten some great shirts camping
gear some cool stuff for the kitchen
from
bespoke post no matter what you're into
box of awesome has you covered from
travel and outdoor gear to breezy summer
styles and grooming goods
box of awesome has collections for every
part of your life they got a few new
boxes built around
coffee that look cool including the
appropriately named turbo box
to get started take the quiz at box of
awesome.com
your answers will help them pick the
right box of awesome for
you they release new boxes every month
across a ton of different categories
it's free to sign up and you can skip a
month or cancel any time
each box costs only 45 bucks but is over
70 dollars worth of gear inside
get 20 off your first monthly box when
you sign up at box of awesome.com
and enter the code ricksplained at
checkout that's box of awesome.com
code ricksplain for 20 off your first
box
also thanks to helix sleep for
sponsoring this episode you don't want
to sleep on a mattress
what's that i like you're doing these on
characters uh-huh yeah you don't want to
sleep on a mattress designed for someone
else
even if that other person is the darkest
timeline version of yourself they
probably like a super firm mad choice
and always sleep on the side of their
body without the eye patch
well helix sleep has a quiz that matches
your body type and sleep preferences to
the perfect mattress for you
they have soft medium and firm
mattresses mattresses great for cooling
you down if you sleep hot hot hot
and even a helix plus mattress for plus
size sleepers
i have a helix mattress and i love it
the quiz match me with a medium firm
mattress with lumbar support and it
sleeps cool
that's right i'm sleeping like i'm
living
cool the mattress ships right to your
door for free
no need to go to a mattress store just
go to helixsleep.comrixplain
take their two-minute sleep quiz and
they'll match you to a customized
mattress that will give you the best
sleep of your life
helix is offering up to 200 off all
mattress orders and two free pillows for
our listeners at helixsleep.com this
show is also sponsored by better help
is there something interfering with your
happiness or preventing you from
achieving your goals
we've all been there at some point
betterhelp will assess your needs and
match you with your own licensed
professional therapist
start communicating in under 48 hours
it's not a crisis line or self-help
it is professional counseling done
securely online there is a broad range
of expertise available for clients
worldwide
log in to your account anytime and send
a message to your counselor
you won't ever have to sit in an
uncomfortable waiting room or look for
parking
better help makes it easy and free to
change counselors if you need to
it's more affordable than traditional
offline counseling and financial aid is
available
betterhelp wants you to start living a
happier life
today visit betterhelp.com that's better
h-e-l-p and join the over 1 million
people who have taken charge of their
mental health with the help of an
experienced professional
in fact so many people have been using
better help that they are recruiting
additional counselors in all 50 states
special offer for explained audience get
10 off your first month
at betterhelp.com explained all right
tommy back to the episode
um do you think the introduction of the
incest baby back in episode 4 now feels
creatively justified
eric as i i am not i'm not there yet
i think it feels much more justified
i feel creatively yeah i
yeah i mean i'm gonna just not be a
little whiny baby boy and say
yes i do i think i think that was good
i'm still really skeeved out by that
that earlier episode
uh more so than maybe i should be maybe
there's a deeper more
i need to go to get some better help and
figure out why that this
really bothered me so much yeah i'll say
i'll say they did i'll say i'm impressed
that's that's all i guess i'll say i
love this episode as did you
but uh yeah yeah that that part is still
to me
it's never gonna feel quite right i
don't think just like incest it'll never
feel quite right
yeah i um look i i'm just happy that
they had
a plan i didn't bother me that much back
in episode four
um but the fact that they had uh a
future in mind for this character and
that you could argue it is thematically
justified
by the power of family it's just family
times family and virgin family
yeah it's kind of like a gross extreme
delusional version
of trusting family too much and that we
only trust our own bloodline the way
like
ancient royal families would force their
kids to have success so that they could
keep the bloodline pure
uh yeah that's probably an extreme take
on it but
hey i thought it was super fun uh and i
loved seeing this thing
being deployed as a weapon and being
named naruto
but uh i guess is there an alternative
that they could have still stuck with
that theme of just having
like a morty clone or a giant morty or
summer clone in that moment
of all the sperm and then it's just some
other random egg
that didn't have to be summer's egg i
guess for summer to be connected to it
it needed to be her
yeah i think it's necessary it's just
still
it's still gross to me it's funny
i like it it's okay i'm all right i'm
coming around on it i love it
i think for many of us like that line
was crossed when
um uh mr jellybean slash king jellybean
assaulted morty and at that point
everything since then
it's just been like all right this is
the show yeah like this is what we
signed up for
yeah you know yeah that's fine yeah but
uh i want to ask you about the voice
ovarians i love this twist
so much um but there was this little
wrinkle to it where so obviously the
voice ovarians can talk to each other
but morty was aware of this voiceover
phenomenon happiness head
summer's body was not aware of it
and they had that little moment where
morty's like well then what's the
difference and then summer's voice
ovarian was like i don't know telepathy
yeah but like why do you think morty
like morty's mind and body
was aware of his voice ovarian whereas
summer's mind and body was not
do you think that tells us something
about the two of their characters
uh my interpretation of it was just that
morty has been has seen so much
more of the universe and
interdimensional
uh existence he's aware of so many more
strange
things i mean summer is becoming more
aware but like
he's just had so much more time with
rick that like
he's not thrown and he can probably
conclude if i'm suddenly having
voiceovers it's these things he might
just be aware of what voice ovarians are
you know
yeah oh yeah maybe that's like an
existing species that he's come across
before
i'm wondering if like remember in total
rick hall morty was the one
to unlock the secret of the virus right
implanting false uh positive memories uh
and without morty's realization they
would have been doomed
so i think you're right i think morty
has experienced so much that that has
kind of like reprogrammed his brain to
be more skeptical and to be aware when
uh
foreign influences may be affecting him
like he knows that there's a morty's
mind-blower episode in season three
right where
where rick has basically uh gaslit and
brainwashed him to forget about certain
things that are too
harmful for him so i think morty is just
more acutely aware
of his own brain and he's even so aware
that he says
some are smarter than he is while morty
may have some mental gaps i think he has
like
very acute self-awareness that uh he
wasn't sure what this thing was but he
knew that it was separate from himself
and it was weird that summer wasn't
aware of it
i just like that little characterization
me too i thought that was i thought that
was a neat little detail i thought that
was cool
and it just shows that like these
writers are aware of how morty is
evolving
over time he is he has a high emotional
intelligence
but i also like how there's that moment
where he's in the back of the car
and the three anime characters they're
like fine we can kill you
and the way he rage snaps when someone
threatens his life
you get to see him like let go of all
fear in that moment just be like
do it do it and he goes crazy and he's
like
willing to let them die he gets the
driver shot he rolls out of the car
like it's like the lighthouse moment in
the uh in the purge episode
or in uh planeteena like one of the
planets
yeah yeah tina tears and he's just snaps
he's like do it and he bites the guy's
finger off like i love seeing morty
go to that place it's just such a fun
way to show how
dark and how messed up the character is
absolutely and yeah
just how yeah how deep he really can go
because it would be
very easy to make him consistently just
morty you know what i mean like where
he's like kind of a pushover and kind of
just trying to
he's a t he's a he's a awkward teenage
boy
but instead they've now added as the
show goes on these like deep
emotional chasms that he can go through
swinging back and forth so
yeah he's like becoming uh i mean the
show is always so delightful
every character is fun to watch in
different ways but like
morty is still the beating heart of the
show and seeing his emotional depths is
something that like
you know the laughs will always keep us
entertained always come back to see what
weird concept they blow up each week
but like i'm attached emotionally to
morty now while he is a little pervert
and a little weirdo
like he does go to these dark places
that like
i mean i remember being a teenager yeah
you do go to these dark places and you
don't really understand them and morty
is not a typical teenager he's seen
he's seen horrible horrible things that
have traumatized him
so like just multiplying those factors
is really fun
to just see where they go with him but i
want to ask you so there's this you know
moment where morty admits
that summer is smarter than him and
summer confessed that she always feels
like the odd one out in the family that
you know
jerry and beth have their pairing rick
and morty always have their pairing and
summer you know she's been kind of been
uh
leaned on this season by rick as a new
morty
uh character and that's created this
rivalry between the siblings
but do you think a rick and summer
pairing
is more interesting to watch than a rick
and morty pairing
because rick and summer have a similar
intellectual nihilism uh that's kind of
terrifying in a way what what are you
thinking about scenery
could the show be brick in summer i no
i'm not for
not for me i think i think the uh
summer is too cool you know
like i i think but in a way that rick is
too cool well
i think they have that in common no i i
agree and i like i like
using her more i mean i would say the
three of them is more interesting to me
than any combination of the two of them
because you get
more they're making summer much more
three-dimensional as a character we're
finding out more things and i mean
some of it is not pleasant some of it is
yeah she's kind of a nihilist doesn't
give
like you know a flying f about anything
no i think rick and morty is the heart
of the show
uh but i like rick morty plus summer i i
want that
more of that i i one thing i've seen
with summer but they've
realized they're doing this all with all
the characters is as they um
put them in these new scenarios and
explore new depths of their
personalities
they still do kind of have their
character game of
uh like what they go back to what's
their comfort zone of things that they
say
and they're all kind of vapid in
different ways and that they
are just like regurgitating like
takes that they read on reddit or
twitter or whatever their social media
is for jerry it might even starting to
be like parlor
yeah you know like jerry says oh makes
you wonder what they're doing with our
tax
dollars or i should get i'm going to the
chiropractor or whatever it's doing to
my prostate
you know summer quotes like her what she
thinks is making her sound woke
but she clearly doesn't understand the
historical significance of what she's
saying
rick is the classic edge lord and he's
one step away from saying we live in a
world sincerely
you know uh like
and morty is just like he goes back to
his simple teen anxieties
yeah uh teenager that's just like you
know like one minute he's
like doing a dance the next minute he's
like trying to butt chug him out and do
like he's just it's just all stupid but
fun yeah so
if rick has read it uh morty is a
tick-tock
or a summer tick-tock tick-tock
yeah summer's also kind of twitter a
little bit you know yeah
um jerry is either facebook or parlor
what would beth be what's social media's
pinterest uh i was about to say maybe
pinterest
uh yeah yeah or i'm trying to think of
like what's one that like they've tried
to
get off the ground but it just like
there's always those things where
they're like the new thing
is is grabble if you're not on gravel
you can post video and pictures
and text it's like yes that's what all
social media is now
yeah that is either not on social media
at all
or beth is like on bumble yeah this
might be married to jerry she's
unbuckled
beth is on uh what was it ashley madison
the dating app designed to have affairs
i think we mailed it
uh so we'll leave it there for this
episode of explain it's always a
pleasure
tommy i love watching the show with you
yeah uh some
my easter egg breakdown of all the
little details you missed in this
episode is going to come out tomorrow
tommy and i will be back next week to
react to episode 8.
we're able to get this one early because
the episode came out a bit early but
next week we'll be back to our normal
schedule
uh follow tommy tommy bechtold follow me
at eavos follow new rockstars of course
subscribe to ricksplained wherever you
get your podcasts thank you for watching
and we'll close out with our favorite
moment of the episode
my clothes where'd they go
[Music]
you